[Música]
llegó a francia sufi y petrona la última
secuestrada francesa en el mundo quien
fue liberada junto al opositor maliense
soumaila cissé y dos italianos más
después de haber estado cuatro años
secuestrada por yihadistas en mali el
presidente de manuel macro on la recibió
a su llegada al aeropuerto militar del
suroeste de parís
otra polémica decisión del presidente de
eeuu donald trump anunció que planea
organizar un evento electoral este
sábado en florida y reiniciar así su
campaña tras la hospitalización por kobe
19 contra todo pronóstico el médico
personal aprobó que vuelva a eventos
públicos en esa fecha
armenia está lista para reanudar el
proceso de paz dijo el primer ministro
de este país nicole para xinjiang previo
a la reunión de su canciller y el de
azerbaiyán en moscú invitados por el
gobierno de vladímir putin para
disminuir las tensiones de este
conflicto que ha crecido en los últimos
15 días tenemos reporte desde la capital
rusa
hola como estan saludamos con gusto a
todos ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france 24 mi nombre es alan
austria llegó a francia subí petrona
donde fue recibida por el presidente
francés emmanuel macrón quien expresó
alegría y alivio por la liberación
petrona era la última francesa
secuestrada en el mundo quien tras
cuatro años de detención a manos de los
yihadistas fue liberada al mismo tiempo
que el político maliense soumaila cissé
y dos italianos este jueves en mali
aterrizó en un aeropuerto militar al
suroeste de parís los miembros de la
familia la recibieron con fuertes
abrazos mientras descendía del avión
tras un motivo reencuentro con su hijo
al descender en mali
petrona de 75 años dijo a los reporteros
que su intención es regresar al país
africano para asegurarse de que la
organización humanitaria a favor de los
niños que dirigía antes de ser
secuestrada siga funcionando
correctamente
y las lágrimas de alegría son del hijo
de sufi petrona luego de que ella se
bajó del avión en bamako su hijo que
jugó un papel fundamental en su
liberación solo lamentó que no hubiese
ocurrido antes
hice lo mejor que pude
pero existe lo que pudiste hiciste lo
que necesitabas pero no fue suficiente
[Música]
no te dije nadie es perfecto en este
mundo
de todas por su parte dijo que nunca
perdió la esperanza
en el fondo siempre estaba asegura que
volvería que no moriría mientras tanto y
me dije a mí misma no le des tanta
importancia a la muerte porque no sabes
dónde cuándo cómo pasará
y como el amigo me habló entonces me
dije no importa sigue adelante
mantente fuertes espera era el dicho de
mi hijo fue lo que dijo en un vídeo
espera espera y eso fue lo que hice la
mujer de 75 años quien dirigía una
organización para huérfanos fue
secuestrada por los yihadistas en mali
en 2016 liberada junto a otros tres
retenidos persona fue la última francesa
secuestrada en todo el mundo ella le
dijo a los periodistas en bamako que
planeaba ir a francia oa suiza en un
tiempo cercano pero eventualmente espera
regresar a malí para continuar con su
trabajo de caridad
nos vamos a eeuu y es que pese a que
este sábado se cumplen sólo 10 días
desde que el presidente de donald trump
fue diagnosticado con kobe 19 el
mandatario indicó que se siente muy bien
y que tratará de organizar un evento
electoral en florida para mañana en un
sorpresivo movimiento el médico personal
del presidente aprobó que vuelva a sus
actos públicos en esta fecha la decisión
ha causado polémica en el país vamos a
este informe de valentina de autor
sánchez regresar a su campaña aparece el
principal objetivo del presidente de
hace sólo nueve días fue diagnosticado
con kobe 19 pero pretende realizar un
mitin este sábado 10 de octubre en
florida así lo aseguró en una entrevista
con fox news en la que se hicieron
presentes algunos ataques de tos pero
vimos a los médicos hoy que creen que
estoy muy bien estoy muy bien lo sé y se
los digo tome el regeneró y es fenomenal
creo que trataré de realizar un wiki del
sábado de la noche
si podemos si tenemos suficiente tiempo
para afirmarlo pero queremos hacer un
mitin florido probablemente el sábado en
la noche
pensilvania la noche siguiente el
presidente agregó que hoy se realizará
una nueva prueba al tiempo que desestimó
su valor al señalar que no es necesario
hacerse test todo el tiempo
volver a la escena pública es otra de
las controversiales decisiones del
mandatario desde que resultó positivo no
obstante en un sorpresivo anuncio el
médico personal del jefe de estado
mostró su respaldo el sábado será el
décimo día desde el diagnóstico del
pasado jueves y basada en la trayectoria
de diagnóstico avanzada que el equipo
médico ha estado conduciendo anticipo
por completo el regreso seguro del
presidente a sus compromisos públicos en
ese momento el anuncio se produce el
mismo día que el mandatario informó que
no participaría en un debate virtual
contra el bayern el ex vicepresidente
demócrata respondió que tampoco
participaría ante la negativa de trump y
pidió aplazar el encuentro una semana
seguimos en eeuu y es que más de una
docena de personas vinculadas a una
milicia de extrema derecha fueron
detenidas en nueva york acusadas de
planear el secuestro y posible asesinato
de la gobernadora de michigan la
demócrata gray en witmer con tribunal
federal acusó a seis personas de
conspirar para cometer el secuestro no
solo de la gobernadora sino también de
otros funcionarios por lo que se
enfrentan a una condena de cadena
perpetua
el presidente trump la criticó y dijo
que durante la pandemia la gobernadora
había hecho un trabajo terrible y se
atribuyó el mérito de haber descubierto
el complot en su contra
hoy se frustró un peligroso complot
contra la gobernadora de michigan en
lugar de dar gracias ella me llama
supremacista blanco mientras que bardem
y otros demócratas se niegan a condenar
a antifa los anarquistas los saqueadores
y las turbas que incendian ciudades
gobernadas por demócratas la asamblea
nacional constituyente de venezuela
aprobó la llamada ley anti bloqueo que
bajo el argumento de enfrentar las
sanciones financieras de países como
eeuu contra el gobierno de nicolás
maduro le otorga amplios poderes al
presidente la legislación de facultades
para cambiar o firmar acuerdos y
contratos con empresas privadas u otros
gobiernos de forma confidencial y sin la
revisión del parlamento en los sectores
de gran relevancia como el petrolero
diosdado cabello el presidente de esta
asamblea oficialista una institución no
reconocida por algunos países insistió
en que las medidas se harán sin violar
la constitución venezolana
los constituyentes las constituyentes
que estén de acuerdo con aprobar este
proyecto de ley presentados por el
hermano presidente nicolás maduro a
hacerlo con la señal de costumbre
aprobada formalmente la ley anti bloqueo
por la soberanía asamblea nacional
constituyente
bolivia sigue azotada por los incendios
forestales y abre las puertas para ayuda
internacional la presidenta interina
jeanine áñez declaró en estado de
desastre a bolivia y pidió apoyo para
combatir los fuegos que arrasan las
zonas del oriente del país las
autoridades reportaron más de 50
incendios forestales activos pero el
número de focos de calor peligros de
humo superan los 4.000 principalmente
por la sequía y el uso del fuego que
hacen los agricultores para limpiar las
tierras de cultivos
pasamos a información sobre el conflicto
armado entre armenia y azerbayán por el
territorio de nagorno karabaj a armenia
estaría lista para reanudar el proceso
de paz esto dijo el primer ministro del
país en nicole para xinjiang el anuncio
tiene lugar poco después de que se
confirmara que los ministros de asuntos
exteriores de armenia y de azerbaiyán
acudirán a moscú para reunirse con su
homólogo ruso esto tras la invitación
del presidente vladimir putin para
estudiar un posible cese el fuego por
razones humanitarias e intercambiar los
cuerpos de los fallecidos y prisioneros
de este conflicto que ha crecido en los
últimos 15 días
xavier colás nuestro corresponsal en
moscú tiene más detalles de la esperada
reunión
el presidente ruso vladimir putin ha
invitado a los ministros de exteriores
de azerbaiyán y de armenia aquí a moscú
para mantener conversaciones que por lo
menos deriven en un alto el fuego'
nagorno karabaj o una zona donde siguen
los combates después de 11 días de
escalada bélica tanto la parte armenia
como la parte azerbaiyana se han
mostrado dispuestas a participar en
estas conversaciones que podrían servir
por lo menos para que durante un tiempo
de no enfrentamientos ambas partes
pudiesen intercambiar los cadáveres de
algunos soldados fallecidos que sabemos
que son cientos y también para
intercambiar prisioneros de guerra la
zona de nagorno karabaj es disputada
entre armenios y azerbaiyanos azerbaiyán
insiste en defender su integridad
territorial y armenia recuerda que en
qara bagh hay una mayoría armenia que
tiene derecho a la autodeterminación
el huracán delta ahora la categoría 3 se
fortaleció rumbo a eeuu luego de azotar
las playas de cancún en el estado de
quintana roo en mexico
los turistas ya volvieron a disfrutar de
la tranquilidad de la costa mexicana
luego de
este fenómeno dejará fuertes lluvias y
destrucción pero menor a la esperada
luisiana se prepara para su impacto un
mes después de sufrir los estragos del
aura andrea rincón tiene la historia
mientras terminan de recuperarse del
embate del aura los preparativos
comenzaron para recibir a delta en la
costa sur de eeuu principalmente en el
estado de luisiana los residentes
brindaron sus locales con estructuras de
madera y sacos de arena en un ejercicio
rutinario durante la temporada de
huracanes
creo que con cada tormenta que llega hay
algo de preocupación en tu mente hay que
esperar por lo mejor y prepararse para
lo peor
quiero decir va a existir algo de
preocupación pase lo que pase pero hemos
pasado por esto antes solo hay que tomar
las cosas una a la vez
aunque no es tan potente como laura
delta levanto varias advertencias a lo
largo de la costa sur de eeuu se prevé
que el huracán toque tierra con fuerza
el viernes en la tarde en luisiana que
emitió una alerta en la que se espera
marejadas ciclónicas potencialmente
mortales mientras que sus alrededores
los ha visto se rebajaron una categoría
de tormenta tropical se espera que delta
se mueva tierra adentro hasta el estado
de georgia mientras se debilita en el
camino las costas del golfo de méjico
que recibieron el primer impacto se
recuperan luego de que los turistas
regresaron a las playas
destroza algunas habitaciones las
instalaciones de la tele no estaban
destrozados
pues hoy hay más ya estaba más poquito
más caluroso por el fruto más no te voy
a decir que estamos por eso que estamos
así tenemos que abrir para sobrevivir de
hecho estamos sobreviviendo con el
nacional el huracán se debilitó a
categoría 2 al tocar tierra y causó
fuertes lluvias y cortes de energía en
un momento en que esta joya turística
trataba de recuperarse de la crisis
económica que impuso el kobe 19
pasamos con el ganador del premio nobel
de paz y es que el programa mundial de
alimentos es el galardonado este año por
sus esfuerzos en la lucha contra el
hambre el reconocimiento anunciado este
viernes por el comité noruego del nobel
en oslo se otorgó este programa de la
onu por ser una fuerza impulsora en los
esfuerzos para prevenir el uso del
hambre como arma de guerra y de
conflicto
en información deportiva los debutantes
desafían a las leyendas del tenis en las
semifinales del roland garros
stefano tesis y pas contra novak
djokovic y diego schwartzman ante rafael
nadal quien tiene 12 de coronas en parís
enlazamos allá con natalia ruiz buenas
tardes por ahí en la capital francesa a
natalia hablemos de ambos partidos
primero nadal ante suárez man el único
representante latinoamericano que queda
y que llega por primera vez a la
penúltima ronda de este torneo
muy buenos días pues así es diego
schwartzman el argentino que es además
el último jugador en haber vencido a
rafael nadal en polvo de arcilla lo hizo
durante el masters 1000 de roma justo
antes del roland garros y bueno y se
enfrenta a este hombre el español que
pues ha hecho del roland garros o su
fortín y sin embargo pues al español no
se le ha visto muy cómodo con las
condiciones de juego aquí en parís
porque ha hecho frío sobre todo ha
habido muchísimo viento y ha llovido
pero hoy el clima está bastante clemente
así que hoy digamos que va a quejarse un
poco menos de esto y esperar quizás si
logra pasar a una final y conseguir
quizás su treceava corona aquí en a
roland garros y después natalia después
de este partido djokovic el número uno
del mundo jugará con otro debutante en
semifinales de roland garros
el griego sí sí pas
así es y si para que por ahora no ha
logrado nunca por ahora en su carrera
clasificarse a una final de un gran slam
una gran incógnita de este partido que
será el segundo que se juegue este
viernes es saber en qué condiciones
físicas se encuentran nuevas djokovic
porque durante su partido ante el
espanyol o pablo carreño busta pues se
le vio muy incómodo por ejemplo de su
cuello tenía hay un parche y también
tenía un problema en su brazo izquierdo
parecía dolorido hizo pidió que un
fisioterapeuta lo viera durante el
partido así que es una gran incógnita de
saber si ya él logró recuperarse después
de este prácticamente día y medio que
tuvo y si logrará volver a una final
aquí en roland garros un torneo que no
ha ganado desde el año 2016 viene
natalia ruiz pues que disfrutes los
partidos ahí en parís van a estar buenos
muchas gracias dejamos la raqueta y
agarramos la guitarra para finalizar y
es que john lennon hoy cumpliría 80 años
nacido el 9 de octubre de 1940 john
winston ono lennon es uno de los más
grandes músicos de todos los tiempos
fundador de the beatles y protagonista
de una
y cultural que anhelaba una sociedad más
justa cientos de sus canciones se siguen
escuchando en nuestros días
con esta imagen y estos sonidos los
dejamos sigan con más mucho más en
france24
[Música]